どっから出てきた皆さんこういうとこ見たことありませんでしょうか輪っかとかになっ
てるイメージがあるんですけどもうそれのめちゃくちゃでかいバージョンです
広げていきます
あいつだけでご覧くださいヘアのいう可能約半分がほどよくわかんない小さい
チョコレートで埋め尽くされました
毛羽だったんですよ仲良くからの back-on ちっちゃいとこあるじゃないです
かあれ美味しいで食べても食べてもなんかパッと見ばっかにすごい多そうに見えるん
ですけども実際そこに少なくて爪食べるとセガのワッカム
無くなっちゃうねソウルと思って探してたらこういういた増のめっちゃてが見つかった
んでこれでたくさん食べていこうと思いますまあ正直僕はあの若造チョコ大好きなんで
これぐらいの量だったら全然いると思うんですよこれ一枚何個入りなんだろう
17です
ブーブーブーンっ
13だけど407号線副なくとも全部の5000つ美食言うわけですよね
絶対食べまーすというわけでもう指での企画でしょあのどうだとずっとちまちましか
食べれなかった奴がここに無限に広がっているので
全部とは言いませんと全部は無理で晴天ぞただ私は諦めない男
床に広がるこの小さい粒のチョコレートを果たし断固くれるのかどうかもしれないで
不満ですね顔が光りますねまたメディアのかちょっと継承していきたいと思いますでは
行くよ
では早速食べていきたいとおもいます大一番
うんん
虫歯ができそう
[音楽]
ん
ますあのー
本ぐらいあって気づいたんですけど
チョコレート出すのクソ女とプレスドーナッツは目の時はなんか楽しかったのにこの時
はもういやですね指が痛くなる
ん
持っています
ええええええ
voodoo
あああん
あっはぁああ
結構食えると思っていてなぜかというと伸びた爪が小さいんで食べた気がしないんです
よ
かつ込み度的に多く見えるんですけども一個一個
等間隔に広がって売ってるんで実は多くないんですコビーて
まあ5000棟目ですけどペンタブなんですけどそんな雑貨離れておっしゃるで多く
ないんで
無限に増えるという錯覚を起こしますね的錯覚を信じるか信じないとか僕取材になるで
あろうまあ頑張りま
[音楽]
ます
ザーバー糸うわぁ
はーやーは魚人と馬ではやばい
ああ
あーまじでまず普通にいたい真剣に起業しました
そう
者やだあああ
[音楽]
4時前に降りましょうそうん
んでまぁ
あもう
ああ
簡易というわけでとりあえず400粒くらい食ってみたんですけども来てみた感想は8
やばいですね僕はのコンビニで売ってるマーブルチョコだったら魂8箱くってますから
ねあの全然まだ
来ますよそのでたったの400粒くらいでん
にゃーんするような弱い男じゃねえからの僕はまだまだ食べますピザー
[音楽]
ua
はあああ
わーわーずわー
はい快今蔀釣れるか分からないんですけどパッチすぎると不思議な現象が起きます
こちら先ほど見せたんですけども切り傷ができてパッチパッチぱちゅぱしすぎてな爪が
剥がれちゃって梅がはがれて違ってしまいましたすごい痛いでこんなにも痛みがと思う
の後はつらかった普通に家ですやばいチョコレート食うだけで両手経過することあるか
会長現場800粒チョコ食ってるんでちょっと
ハマーちょっとがんばりますではあっ
[音楽]
次へを押す
で後は
[音楽]
me
うううう
car
me
あっはぁ
造形跳ねると約900粒を食べましたちょっとこれ全然無空とすごい良いと思います
糖尿病がちらつくくらいちょっとなんか糖分摂りすぎてやばいなと思いましたこれ駄目
ですねでも普通にクールでてくれてると思うんですよ
2だったらこれだってや孫でご先祖でこんなんだからそれを視覚的には広がってなんか
少ないように見えるし
色もカラフルで食べやすい
小粒なんでこうパクパク食べれる無限に食べてるような状況をつくったんですけどもう
ちょっと莫言で及ばずといった感じでした後チョコをして立つ作業がダメージちょっと
ずつ食らっているそこもちょっと
半位だったかなと思います
たくさん余ってしまいました
スタッフが責任を持って食べさせていただきます
ジャガー